it's not as easy as it was to be young
and Rich after their fortunes surged
last year thanks to a pandemic fueled
burst of momentum in the markets many
young billionaires tumbled down the
wealth rankings in 2022 as rising
inflation and fears of recession Royal
Industries ranging from technology to
use car sales
there are 10 billionaires under the age
of 40 on this year's Forbes 400s list of
the richest Americans down from 15 last
year most of whom fell below the list
2.7 billion dollar cut off or out of the
billionaire rankings altogether amid
wild Market swings the plumbing value of
cryptocurrencies wiped tens of billions
of dollars of wealth from crypto
billionaires including coinbase
co-founder and CEO Brian Armstrong
Armstrong lost nearly 9 billion dollars
over the past year as the value of his
cryptocurrency exchange plummeted 75
percent from about 60 billion dollars
market cap to 15 billion dollars his
coinbase co-founder Fred ursum fell
completely off the list two other
co-founders who lost billions this past
year are Snapchat co-founders Evan
Spiegel and Bobby Murphy both shed about
80 percent of their wealth over the past
year mirroring the downturn in the
shares of their social media company
broader industry struggles were
compounded by Apple's privacy changes
which slash snaps advertising revenues
in August CEO Spiegel announced the
company would lay off 20 of its staff
and discontinue at least six products
only one new youngster debuted on this
year's list Gary Wang the 29 year old
co-founder and chief technology officer
of bahamas-based FTX Wang and his FTX
co-founder Sam bankman free lead this
year's youngest billionaires list with
bankman free being 30 years old